I want to say congrats on the way things
are going in your career and uh jumping
in um so you've done a lot of great
music if someone has never heard
anything you've done what is the first
thing you'd like them listening to and
why wow that's a great question
[Music]
I went before
I'll take it oh yeah that's wonderful
um yeah what would that be I think
I think probably one of my records would
be a good starting point you know
um
I think maybe
I think probably without thinking would
would be my my
um
uh my invitation to to a starting book
perfect I guess because it was um I
think it was through
through working on
these these records that I did
originally like mount a was my my first
one and and without thinking that the
second one it's it's
[Music]
um
I think that's kind of where
where you hear you hear me finding you
know finding my strongest point of
musical resonance Within Myself you know
it's it's a it was it was a very uh um
uh when I when I started working on
those records I've been collaborating
with people for you know for ages and
ages and you know done
you know various you know Orchestra
projects doing Orchestra projects band
projects you know which was there was a
lot of movement and a lot of touring and
and a lot of action and and
um
it was kind of when I started working on
on this music that became these records
that I really allowed myself that the
time and the space to just sit with
myself and my own thoughts for for a
minute and um and I think that's somehow
where
[Music]
um
yeah where where I I just found like
you know I just got in tune with myself
if you will so so so I think that's
probably where
where I feel like um
I started to make sense you are the
first person from Iceland to win an
Oscar and I'm just curious if you have
paid for a drink in Iceland since
that's a good question well I stopped
drinking funnily enough a couple of
years before the uh before the Oscar so
I was like that's so good during the
Oscars
and have been ever since so
um uh so so no I have not paid for my
own drink because I haven't been
drinking
you know what I mean though yeah yeah
yeah
absolutely yeah I'm sure it's a really
big deal anyway um yeah no it's
wonderful and I said because you know
we're such a tiny we're such a tiny uh
culture you know we're such a tiny
population and
um you know of course when
um
when and here when someone when someone
has success like outside of Iceland it's
so beautiful the whole country
participates you know and and it's just
like one I don't know if you remember
when the um when it started to go really
well for the Icelandic football team and
and uh they became the you know that the
you know the the heroes of the world
then we had this new thing and you know
and in Iceland they were called our boys
you know and the whole country just
flocked behind our boys and and we had
this big parade when they came back from
the from the from this uh um from these
tournaments and and uh and that's a
little bit how I felt like when uh um
when around that time of the Oscars you
know I I felt like I became more boys
you know
the whole country was there with me I
became the child of the country you know
it was it was beautiful it's it's really
it's a really
um yeah it's a beautiful Nation you know
a very strong it's so dirty I've
actually been to Iceland I found it it
was very beautiful and uh I could keep
going on on that but I would imagine
over the last few years
um as you become more well-known and
more successful more people are talking
to you about hey would you like to do
the music for my project so how do you
decide what's something that I want to
work on say when you're being offered a
few different things
well there are a few different things
that are that are very important to me
when um
when I start working on a on a project
or I decide to to join a project and
that's probably first and foremost
whether I like the people that are that
are working on it they're not that's a
very very very big
um big factor for me because
um
you know you spend a lot of time working
on these films and and if you don't like
the people involved they can
it can get pretty uh difficult
yes exactly it can be complicated but um
you know so that's probably the first
the first factor and then the second
factor is is of course whether I have
the time or not because yeah I'm also
someone who
you know I really like to to take my
time to to work on a project and I I
normally don't take anything on unless I
know that I can really dive deep into it
and I'm not
um you know I don't have a team of
people that I work with and you know I I
really
uh you know so I don't have this factory
setting you know I have a um a you know
a couple of people that are very close
to me my husband and my best friend and
my little brother who who sometimes
helped me you know with with conforms or
mixing or or you know production work
but but the right thing the right thing
I really prefer just to do by myself in
a room with no disturbance and to really
just like live inside the project that
I'm that I'm working on and
um
uh so so so the time factor is is a very
big one and then of course it's a
question of whether or not I feel like I
can
if I can bring anything of value or
interest to the tools up story or the
project you know because I I need to
feel that that
um my contribution is is you know
bringing something
interesting or or or elevating to the to
the project and and that you know even
if you
you know even if there are many projects
that have come come my way that you know
would be great to do or exciting to do
you know if I feel like
it's not within my range to do it or if
it's not within my um you know scope of
Interest or if I feel like it's going to
be
um
you know too too
um too narrow minded for me you know
because I also I I like to have a lot of
or certain amount of freedom and and and
space to explore
with within within the project you know
so all of these factors are you know
coming to into play so I right so I end
up not doing very many projects I
understand
um talk a little bit about some of the
unique challenges that you faced for
Haunting in Venice
um uh and if you could talk a little bit
about that
um
um well
really
um really fun to work into uh um because
I I really grew up with Agatha Christie
and I grew up reading
you know her books and Sherlock Holmes
and Nancy Drew like I I really was
raised on on detective novels so so I
already had a very strong idea
about what um what I feel like this
genre should sound like so so
um so it was just like a great place for
me to to explore whether these ideas
that I that I have like these temples
that I was that I was feeling
when I was reading uh these novels like
whether they were actually you know
applicable to to an actual project or
not so so it was really fun for me to be
able to to work into this um into this
genre and with with an Agatha Christie
story
and that I guess came with um
you know those that that was kind of
both the pro and that and the con
because because I already set up very
strong um
strong uh um
frame framework for me to to work into
but the great thing was also that like
the Canon had such a strong idea but
what he wanted to do for the film and
what he wanted it to sound like and and
you know he wanted it to be very
different from the from the other films
and he wanted it to be very dark and and
um a tonal and much
um more confined like the sound quality
you wanted like a chamber piece rather
than an orchestral
because sweeping orchestral score you
know so so we had all these um really
great uh guidelines to work into and he
and he really stuck with them throughout
the whole process of of making the film
so I was able to to write a lot of the
music very early on
in the process she says they were
finishing their their shooting uh I
wrote a lot of the key
um pieces of music that they even
implemented into the edit as as they
were starting to assemble that and the
film together so so that's a beautiful
way of working I think we're the where
the music and the film
really grow together like organically
and you know and you can have an actual
dialogue between the um between the
different
um uh different uh art forms of of the
film you know the the editing and the
acting and the music and the um you know
everything comes together it's so
interesting because I've spoken to some
composers who will write so much of the
music before they've seen any footage
and then others who don't want to write
anything until they've seen visuals and
there's no right answer it's just how
people like to work yeah exactly no it's
it's really just it's it's really just a
yeah which is a personal preference and
I and I totally understand I totally
understand both both ways but I think
for me
it is
um
uh I think like from when you read the
script you know you you have you already
have such a strong feeling of like how
you experience the tempo and uh of of
the story you know and I think the more
that that um
the more of that that are just like
initial sense of the story that you feel
the more you can bring that into the um
um into the into the fold early on like
the um
the kind of the deeper dialogue you can
have between the um between the the
different elements of the film I think
because then the added starts to
respond like the acting can like in
Joker for example the acting is really
responding to the music you know he's
literally dancing to this uh he's being
led by the music and dances to the music
you know so so uh in the same way with
that within this film like that the
added is really following the pacing of
the of the music you know uh I I think
in that sense you can connect all the
elements can grow together
very organically I I feel in my uh in in
my opinion like in in the way that I
work yeah I'm curious when you how long
does it actually take you through
something like The Haunting in Venice
when you like how long is your process
are you on the film for three months are
you on the film for six months is that
the thing that you're solely working on
like how long does it typically take you
to to work on something well that really
just depends on uh um
when I come
I come into the project of course uh um
to begin with
so so that can vary like if if I if I
start
um before the shooting or infrastructure
like
um after uh and normally I will I would
start
um before the film is shot you know so I
will normally have music that they can
listen to uh on set
and in this sense I started working uh
on the film
um as they were um as they were already
shooting so they were listening to my
music uh my records on on the set but
but it was it wasn't until they started
editing that they actually had uh
original music for the um for the film
so so this project was a little bit on
the shorter side of what I you know
normally would do so so I I started
working
on this film in
December and we finished in in uh well
in August really so so yeah it's about
seven months you know but but it can be
all up to like you know three years
sometimes that uh from from start to
finish but I start really early so
it depends on the project I completely
get it um I have to wrap with you I'm
just gonna say that I am obviously
looking forward to your
uh contributions to the Joker sequel
thank you thank you very much on that
note have a fantastic day thank you you
too